うーん
蘇武米軍つけすぎたーー今日はエアコン付杉田肇社長ですうんぬサブウェイなぁ
でしょうねというわけで今日は肇社長の1日密着動画でございまーす
疼く朝生田持しての7時にを着てて二度寝して
本部サンズになりました
a つ今日は
9時からミーティングですね
最近何が多いかっていうと動画とかじゃなくてミーティング出すが多いんですよね
日やけを受ける巨
東京すごい長いともう一回寝させていただきましたはいという意味でまずはですね起き
たらうってで臭くちゃってね癖が直らないかちょっとやってみてます
出口歳の俺ば朝は ok です
[音楽]
すごい意味
それで待ち時間なんじゃない入った容器で急いでおりますとりあえず歯磨きはします
はい
いう苦しい場にいても優秀な山へ行くよ
なんでこうなったっていうんで偶然のチョコレートと強いんだから
よあーくそー治らんカッターもしてくださいなー
応援とネルってね癖が直らないですマジで腹立つだけでタクシーを呼びます
me
んおおぉタクシーお願いします
はい暮らしの日と比べて何が変わったかというと
ちゃんと寝るようになったんですよ2次3次4次5時ぐらいまでなんか
ゲームしたり公開とカードゲームとかしてたブスごすっと
阿含入っていますはいというわけで9時に8事務所に向かいます
クズなんでもう集合時間ですね結構ギリギリになってしまいましたぁホント申し訳ない
です
というわけで無事事務所に到着しました
はい結構近くに住んでいます
操作くれません
一つはちょっと裏もこんなときになったんですね
これから帰ったというを込めてくれって
で僕らが輪番であえて
実はちょっと風月中で色々覚えていたしましたこの後からぴょん
麻生いらっしゃいますということでうむの偉い人とはミーティングが終わりました
ちょっとライブのね今変化しようと頑張っています
あのビル動画農主義運転が変わってきたかっていう間になっております突発ために今
海野宿を前になってもめっちゃ見てが伸びているようなループでしてパーンいただく
ゲーターがたと言ってタップしてると言われております
マイクラリマーシーマン活動をしているところがクレカが来いってんっていう子
消えたと思っ
スペクラいるチームでも黙って橋ものが幕府医療供給がとっていますん
悪童5
はい
確かに行っちょっと接続不良未来的な土砂という
あっておりますこれもエッグ
お父様でちょっとことさせながら若干イヤーぜひともという感じなんですけどその一派
どこで出すとかっていうのも難しいんでちょっと他にもですねチャンネルどうするかと
か今後の動きとかっていうのを総立ちてもらったりもしていますいろいろ専門の方が
いらっしゃるんでそこに聴いてます
てるのって
パッチャーができるかもみたいな萩市そうな感じで受けたらなと僕は王となった
解説のびるラベル艦隊の
ちょっとした隙間時間にはなんかそのフラ別をどうするかという相談もせてもらって
ますじゃあまあゲーム企画のゲーム脂肪に関してのご相談しております
でまぁ今までアンマン前回の空になりますかこのようなところが一応ある程度決まって
いると
って前から僕が一番重要な思ってるのはまあ
やっぱり一さんが好きなものを作るためにひっくり返してみましょう
喧嘩デー
はいというわけでいろいろミーティングをたところ十時半になってましたはい
そしてここが初めはですね8僕のブームの事務所にあるお部屋です
今日午前中までデー
ちょっとまとめ
んねえっ
こちらから今来て要望等はチョコ良かったぜはい続けて別のミーティングです
日々日々話すことがとても多くなってますね
んですけども貴重です考える時間が本当に
手術回戦の16巻がう
これはですねはじめグって言う僕だファンクラブ抜けの動画の撮影ですねはいファン
クラブにもあのめちゃくちゃ何か出来てるわけじゃないんですけども
できることをやっています皆さん入ってねー
体幹くらい配備済みだエロい訳ではなく普通にあの税新3 d スキャンのために母に
なっております
精密にしっかりと体の大きさを測るために動いではいけないという作業がかなり長い
時間かかりました
ちょっと苔がありますがそれもまあを増えてはるん
ani
アップって
てくれた釧路
ありがとうございましてっ
ただいまーーす帰宅しました痴漢隊
はい1:00くらいですね
ちょうどお昼です午前2は一切動画撮影とそういうことはせずひたすらミーティングを
やりまくるっていう通知でした
平均そういう日がめちゃくちゃ多いんですけどやっぱ関わってくださる方が多かったり
考えてから動く仕事が多いんでやむを得ない時間だと思っておりますこういうのは
たぶんねー
俺のツイッターと同神と伝わらない時間だと思うんでこういう感じで半日終わったり
することがあります
お昼ご飯はサラダですいただきますねっそうしそうでしょ
入ってあげサラダを食べながらちょっと趣味が時間ですこれ漫画読んでんのかな今その
ままがれてますね
はい他にも今魚紋5をやったりして
こういうのでね趣味に時間を使ったりしています
すぐ水が時間なんですよ大事だと思っていますごはん食べてまもなく動画を取り外れ
ました
はいちょっとねこの日は時間がなかったので手っ取り早く簡単ね動画だったんですけど
も
ちょっととっている瞬間はこんな感じですどうぞ
また一方でもう一方でラークとライダーの特性
もう一方でなくトレード特定の人がリーダー七宝
まだまた一方でダークトレード特定の人がリーダーシップ気質はそれだけ鋭いから
いろんなことができるんですよ多分それだけ鋭いに人と違ったことが好準備から
その一つ金なんかそれだけ人と違うんでいろんな人がしないようなことを率先してでき
たりするんですよという欲も悪者みたいなと言うよと丸尾みたいなところもあるんです
けども一人で撮影する時本当こだわりが強くてもう簡単な動画でも撮影の1時間近く
かかったりしてしまいます
僕はバッチリ
ダメでした
じゃん
落ち込む
th
よしメイン取れました
て後ちょっと編集したかったのけどすぐこの後ですね伊蔵選挙いけないのでちょっと
移動します
マネージャーさんが迎えに来て下さって次の現場への移動です今日はですねこの後よる
熱海で撮影があります
ええええええ
お願いします
うわぁ出ました出ましたねまた下がっ館だよりのは何なので寝ちゃったらあってから
決めて欲しいでもそれだけ
さぁさぁとりあえずあのサベが全く動かせてないっていう実はちょっとわかってほしい
はい会社関係の電話をしてますね基本はのかなちゃんと話してるんですけどもうお礼の
言いたいことをしっかり失っを向こうもちゃんとしたことをしっかり言ってくれるん
じゃないかなんかちょっとバチバチな感じになりますけれども本当にためになる
大事な会話だと思っていますはい
あのね俺母ちゃんねめっちゃ叱られるんですけどやっぱ怒られる人がいることって
すごい大事だと思うんでこういうふうには真面目な話に打つピア
か見ましたけどがぶつかりあったりする時間はとても化粧以上ね見てないんだと1回
見るか話すかして欲しいよ
そうだから提案ベース切ってるわけです雇う努力トヨタはね努力をすべきだと思うから
ございます
話だけで起きてあげてほしいなって感じです陳述大宣言開けとかでもいい気もする
はいありがとうございますああやばいされずれますはいはいあじゃあ
ダックそしてと車に乗りました午後5時です
もう車酔いとか関係なく au に編集を進めております
やらなければいけないとか車の中でもうするしか間に合わないんでほとんど車酔いする
人は結構苦しいんじゃないですかねもう
一言も話さずずっと編集しています
低時間が過ぎて午後の6時です
最近に暗くなるのが遅くなったのでもう6時7時とかでもそんなに暗くなかったりし
ますね
はい
今たぶん7時ぐらいですね
午後の執事でもこれくらいの暗さですはい
橋バスト編集を進めております
はいもう現場が使いねちょっと子がここで編集間に合わないなぁとまでちょっと焦って
きました
鈴スケール
1,009件これです
ただあれございます
あとに到着しました
尺6月よ12
3つを避けれますカメラのセッティング中です
カメラのセッティングしつつ俺今日の動画間に合わねえだと思ってずっと不安な気持ち
でいっぱいでしたこの土地はアイマム大天守します
ブーブー
逆光中でもまずはサムネの撮影でもう youtube といえばサムリーがとっても
大事なのでどこで取ればいいのか
この豪華客船を使ってどういう様に劣るとかをずっと考えています
高めだったらめっちゃ強そうだなぁ
d すんの
言えばいい感じで攻めています
ちょっとあった怖かったんですけどもしっかりともうあらゆる角度を
と後半にしづして撮ってもらっています本当にとりあえず武に
がすごい取りたいんですごい時間かけて撮っていますどれかは見てるだけ
はい初中になりましたなんか合間を縫って編集してなんとかどうかが真になりました
良かったです
ブーブー
[音楽]
ブーバー4泊郷湖カヌーダブルチーズバーガーハチ子
社員ぞサンドゥ
東京のつ帰ってきましたーー23ず4分でございます高かった
朝9時ぐらいから始まって
11時ぐらいですねという感じでまとったど動画で撮っただけでダメなんで今日のあの
熱海
動画とかもちゃんとこの後編集しなきゃいけないんですけど今日はやめておきます今日
多分忙しいヒットタイプだね忙しいん
東京いうだけ基本忙しいんですよこういう動画ガイノス事は絶対あるんでこういう感じ
の日もありつつでも今日特徴としてはフラベジ関係が一個やってないんで触れ+比べ
時間系のお仕事とか撮影とか話し合いとかもあるって言うのが最近の外れ社長の動画街
の感じです
さすがに酒を飲んで今日は
[音楽]
ねますいう感じの1日密着でございましたねーよねぇいいましょう
よし
[拍手]
ハンドはん
僕別のかっ
じゃないかなパワーアクセル30点
うするに入れるとしてめえっ
とっても強い
[音楽]
blr